samedi 19h une marée de partisans manque
vers le stade saputo
la plupart connaissaient bien peu
l'impact il y a quelques années
aujourd'hui il porte fièrement le bleu
blanc noir suffit d'une fois d'un mètre
à piedmont ce stade là et on est
convertie à jamais de quelque chose de
magique c'est qu'ils vous préférez et
pyatt qui - laurence mans le feeling
qu'on nous car toute la foule se lève
plus on est du côté 16 42 la cloche de
l'église
ambiance du tonnerre
ils sont encore plus de 20000 encourager
l'impact pour son septième match à
domicile de la saison jusqu'ici l'équipe
a attiré en moyenne 22 mille spectateurs
par match c'était 18 né l'an dernier on
était à guichets fermés
quatre fois au printemps ce que jamais
arrivé dans le passé
la stabilité vient justement des billets
de saison souvent on n'a pas assez de
6000 quelques billets à plus de 9500
alors ça fait qu'on on a toujours une
clientèle qui tue les groupes sont plus
réguliers aussi alors c'est tout seul
cette année
avoir fait la finale l'an dernier de la
ligue des champions ou compétitionne
meilleures équipes d'amérique centrale
et d'amérique du nord a donné un élan
et bien sûr il y a eu didier drogba
arrivé en héros en juillet après avoir
choisi montréal pour terminer sa
carrière
samedi le légendaire ivoirien a encore
multiplié les prouesses sur le terrain
je te dirais quatre matches sur cinq
dans la mls sont très bons et sont
excitants donc en attendant de devenir
un des plus grands les gourmands au
moins on a un très bon produit sur le
terrain plus même quand didier drogba va
partir je pense que l'impact faut faire
des efforts pour aller chercher d'autres
bons joueurs comme symacom piatti jeremy
filosa et arcadio marcousis décrivent
les matchs de l'impact à la radio on
sent de plus en plus les gens nous
posent des questions sur l'équipe a été
le joueur il n'y étant pas blacy revient
quand son équipe nationale ça c'est très
bon signe
dans la conversation tous les jours dans
les cafés dans les bureaux les collègues
tout seul le foot commence à faire
partie de la conversation quotidienne et
c'est là qu'on voit vraiment que la
culture soit carl et grandes sont tous
plantés le pigeon très très jeune 50 %
de notre clientèle et entre 18 et 35 75%
est en mode 45,6 et beaucoup les jeunes
couples et des jeunes familles et
évidemment la dimension familiale parce
que le soccer étant le sport de
participation numéro un
on le voit avant les matches ici les
jeunes peuvent venir jouer au ballon et
on les voit jouer en famille l'impact à
plus de difficultés à attirer les anglo
montréalais de l'ouest de l'île
passionné de soccer les communautés
culturelles
elle représente environ 25 % de la
clientèle
réunis dans les bars de montréal en ce
début d'été
c'est plutôt l'euro ou la copa america
qui ont monopolisé leur attention à fond
derrière le pays d'origine
mais quand même de plus en plus
intéressés l'impact soit jeu les joueurs
comme hong bao plein de place ça ça
reste supergirl à montréal aux nageurs
c'est le manque à peu près là ça qui
nous intéresse quand même comme une
communauté non comme on peut pas te
regarder parce qu'à jouer regardez
mariage ou et s'était fait un plaisir
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui viennent
à la table et que dit et merci d'être
ici parce que et ça fait loin que je
suis parvenu à leicester à l'estac
mais maintenant que c'est toi je viens
je pense que le pari a été gagné en fait
lorsque je marche dans la rue à travers
les années joie joie je vois qu'on mais
on est de plus en plus populaire il ya
une effervescence
vraiment vraiment beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus intense au fil des années est-ce
quelque chose d ordinaire content de
vivre cet engouement les joueurs savent
que le plus dur reste à faire gagner
faire rêver se rendent jusqu'à la cour
entrée l'impact encore plus solidement
dans le paysage montréalais